FROM HOME.
>> Josh: LINDBERGH FOR HOLDING.
GOAL, BARKOV.  FIRST PERIOD
IN THAT REGARD. THE STARS HAVE
STRUGGLED TO MOVE THE PUCKCK
>> Daryl: I LO CENTER.
DIRK. WE ARE COUNTING DOWN THE
DAYS, JUST OVER ONLY THE
>> Josh: E THE BANE OF EVERY
PENALTY KILL. THE PANTHERS  CON
THEY NEED MORE OF THAT.UTER IS
AT THE REFEREE IN THE WAKE OF
THIS.
>> Daryl: NO
>> Daryl: THIS IS SUCH A SMART
INTERCHANGE . UP TOPTHE ATTACK.
SAVEDRECHECK BY TYLER
SEGUIN  TO BENECT.
WEEGAR KEEPS IT   HAKANPAA, AND
>> Daryl: THERE IS REALLY NO
NEED FOR BOBROVSKY  TO DO
ANYTHING  OFF THE CHEST OF HOLT
THE PUCK T A BREATH TO COME BAC
HERE NOW.END OF THE RINK VER PE
BENN.
TAKEN AWAY.
HEISKANEN
HIS GLOVE SIDE.
THE KID HAS BEEN GREAT.
SCORE!
WAIT, ANTICIPATING SOMETHING
ELSE.
GRAVITY NOT ON